big mistake canceling me the way they
did and then the second time the second
life which I described as they try and
put you in jail for no reason here we
are in the current scenario I knew it
was going to happen and the third one is
they put a bullet in your head so we're
gonna have to see
how the second life plays out and
yeah I mean when this is all over and I
win the court case I get the not guilty
I won't be smiling I'll be walking out
the courtroom with my head on a swivel
that's the kind of life I'm living now
I'm gonna be thinking oh okay so their
second attempt failed now what like do I
want to fly private anymore do I want to
go that place anymore you start to think
about these things like do I want to do
these things law billionaires dying in
plane crashes is strange it's scary
regardless of how it plays out so you
see the way he's talking right now he
already knows they're going to court
he's thinking about not guilty versus
guilty it's not even about charging not
being laid they've changed the language
so if you aren't aware it appears that
Andrew Tate's most likely going to get
charged with all the crimes that the
Romanian Goods alleges against him a lot
of evidence been coming out a lot of
discussions about stuff but this is a
lot of stuff that we the public are not
privy to Who's involved what's going on
and yeah you know he did an interview
with Patrick Bet Davis uh which right
now is garnering with lots of views
people were talking about it and with
him being charged very soon I think you
post on Twitter that they're expecting
him at the police station tomorrow for
the charges
um with all intents and purposes who
knows maybe tomorrow they come around
the Roman government's like man we just
[__] around we're not doing nothing but
it seems like everyone involved knows
charges are coming so what are your
thoughts you're I think initially were
expecting him not to get charged yeah I
was like God damn man
and initially actually initially what I
said was
if you're doing all this [__] and you
don't you better charge him with doing
all this circus if you're doing all that
you better because now you're gonna
create a martyr I said that remember
when I said that sure okay then she was
driving and I was like man they're not
going to charge this man the reason why
I said that is because in life I don't
really have a lot of Hope for a lot of
things
yes or no
yes or no yes or no this guy always
thinks the worst is going to happen yes
yes prepare for the worse if you prepare
for the worst the best is gonna happen
you're prepared for the worst so if the
worst happens you're like I prepare for
that [__] but then if good [__] happened
you're like hey so wait are you trying
to say the best situation is one in
which Andrew Tate is charged no I just
it sounds like that's what you're saying
are you one of them [__] Matrix Bots
no I'm not happy I don't have the best
situation no but what I'm saying is I
always prepare for the worst and if you
do all that circus and you don't charge
them that's the worst that's gonna
happen because then [__] like
invincible and stuff like that and you
cannot and the other if there's other
real charges and everything and stuff to
happen
they're not gonna be able to charge them
now
best charge him if he actually did
something you understand
of course it don't look good but there's
so many cases that I've seen that they
don't charge and they're not able to
charge and stuff like that and they drop
this and they dropped that so now I'm
just like man I just go on the if
something happens I'm like I just
straight up go to but I gotta charge it
and then
life surprised me or not like this I
don't I don't exactly know what he did
you know I mean so I don't know yeah I
always thought he was going to get
charged I never really doubted I think
with these kinds of Investigations I
think people expect charges to be
instantaneous but that's just not the
way police investigations work
especially not ones on this governmental
scale even look at the FBI the FBI
builds a case for four or five years
before they charge someone and when they
charge you best believe they bring the
whole [__] roof down that's why
generally governmental charges from like
big organizations like the FBI things
like that always stick is because
they've done a lot of investigating
they've pulled on every thread and what
ends up happening generally with a lot
of like criminal organizations which is
what their alleged criminal Andrew Tate
is part of is that when they pull on one
thread all of a sudden they start
finding different threads and they find
like oh organized crime money laundering
tax evasion try track whatever it might
be and so that's why irrespective how
you feel about the investigation when
these things take a long time for
charges to be laid it's not because they
don't have a case which may be the case
in the situation maybe they don't have a
case who knows like everyone who
speaking on it doesn't exactly know
enough but to say it's not credible
because it's taking a long time that's
just not the case that's why they always
say here in the state specifically is
like they bring a RICO charge against
you it's already over because they
already got everything they need they
got snitches they got wire Taps they got
Bank transfers they got phone records
right they generally do the things the
same way now from what I've read up on
there was a Romanian newspaper that put
out a news report saying like there's
very strong ties between the Tates and
the mafia over there and different
organized crime and the lawyer who's
actually Prosecuting the case is the top
lawyer when it comes to Prosecuting
organized crime so do I believe that
there's no case no I believe that
there's some case do I believe that Tate
is inherently going to be found guilty
not necessarily it's very possible that
he gets off and if he does and the
courts have found him to be not guilty
then it is what it is like at the end of
the day we have a system in place for a
reason and it's supposed to work and if
it goes into it and then it finds I'm
not guilty then everybody gotta just eat
them keep it pushing you can't just sit
there and be like no he's definitely 100
I mean actually you can you can say
whatever you want technically speaking
but uh you just gotta let the system
play play itself out me personally I'm
not invested I know some people think
like [__] sit at home thinking
about Tate every day or whatever but
it's like if he's found guilty cool if
he's found not guilty cool I think
everything should be decided on the
merits of the case itself now everyone
wants to be an armchair lawyer and say
he's 100 this or 100 that all I know
is from what I've seen from his
Hustler's University which now he wants
no ties to the videos of him talking
about his course teaching how men how to
get girls to be on a webcaming business
and how to steal their money and lie to
them about how much they're getting paid
so you can keep higher profits he's
definitely done some illegal stuff now
those aren't the things he's necessarily
on trial for but it shows me that in the
past he's done some criminal stuff sorry
I don't care what anybody says I don't
care how much you want to send for the
man how much you hate only fans women or
whatever any employer who says you
getting this cut and then they're taking
off a percentage of this by lying to you
about what the actual costs are they're
stealing your money that has always been
my biggest contention with this the rest
of it needs to be proven for me to have
a real issue with so that's where I
stand on I'm just gonna sit down and
watch
I'm gonna sit down I watch and if the
leader of the tournament is going to be
able to be there and break it break it
down imma watch that
I'm not a lawyer they're not gonna put
cameras in a Romanian Court that's not
it's not America not everything is for
TV everywhere that's not wrong yeah but
yeah like all that to say I was gonna
sit down and watch what's going on yeah
the worst thing I know that in cases
like that the worst thing can happen is
that
If you deny
things that is very provable that you
did yeah you get a worse sentence and if
you just say you know what
I did it so if you keep on denying that
[__]
I'm just gonna watch I'm just gonna
watch what's going on see what's going
on whatever yeah well we'll see what
goes down but yeah that's what's going
on with this case it's been interesting
watching him post indictment or like you
know post incarceration and all the
above I don't know if his influence is
what it used to be but it seems like
it's still very relevant uh to some
degree online I can tell this is going
to be one of those court cases that are
going to be really big but I'm just
saying I don't necessarily believe in
The Matrix but Andrew Tate and Donald
Trump getting charged at the same time
is kind of wild
once in a while it's the same timing the
two biggest names on the side of like
against cancer culture getting charged
at the same time that's crazy same day
in two different continents across two
oceans
you don't see the way the system is
working in synchronicity no
don't last kind of crazy two of the most
influential men right Andrew Tate is one
of the most Googled men on the planet
Donald Trump
he trying to be the president to drink
the swamp and they trying to get his ass
too
you know that's crazy they both get in
charge at the same time you don't think
there's any
I thought you believed in the worst you
don't think that's the worst no
see this guy's just a skeptic about
everything he don't believe nothing you
don't think anything's ever gonna happen
is
just bringing proof oh well yeah yeah
I'm so bad because I want people to
bring me proof
yeah yeah he thinks it's all just chance
Andrew Tate Donald Trump getting charged
at exactly the same time across two kind
of he thinks it's just a chance to say I
don't know
I think that these guys will try to
deprogram a lot of people and now the
New World Order is making an example out
of them by charging at the same time to
let anybody know who wants to come
afterwards we'll round up all you
[__] naysayers all you guys are
Against the Machine and then we'll grind
you into the [__] gears and spit you
back out faster than you can say Yeehaw
you don't see it
I'm just saying this is what you guys
think in the comments y'all think this
is a conspiracy do you guys think that
all these people getting rounded up
together is is a
random event or do you think that the
leader of young men like these guys
okay
it's a coincidence that the feminists
are coming for
what nothing you used to identify as a
feminist why are you acting like you
don't die
you don't think I'd be looking at you
something might still be perfect